When I ask you a question is your life's
blueprint,
this is the most important and crucial
period of your life.
What you do now and what you decide now
at this age may well determine which way
your life shall go,
and whenever a building is constructed,
you usually to have an architect who
draws a blueprint and that blueprint
serves as the pattern as the guy,
as the model for those who are to build
the building and a building is not well
erect it without a good sound solid
blueprint.
Now,
each of you is in the process building
the structure,
have you alive,
and the question is whether you have a
prop or a solid sound blueprint,
and I want to suggest some of the things
that should be and your life's
blueprint.
Number one in your life's blueprint
should be belief and your own dignity or
your own worth and your own.
Somebody this don't allow anybody to
make you feel that you are nobody.
Always feel that you count,
always feel that you have worth,
and I always feel that your life has
significance.
Don't be ashamed.
Don't be ashamed of your biological
features.
Somehow you must be able to say in your
own lives and really believe in,
I am black but beautiful.
Oh yeah.
Your Life's blood that a principal or
somebody in his second lap and your
life's blueprint.
Okay.
You must have as a basic principle,
they did termination to achieve
excellence in your various fields in
that barn.
You're going to be deciding as the days
and the years what you will do in life,
what your life's work will be.
Yeah.
Once you discover what it will be set
out to do it and to do it well,
and I say to you,
my young friends,
that opening to each of you know some
opportunity opening the each of you that
were not open to your mothers and
fathers and the greatest challenge
facing you is to be ready to enter these
doors as they opened.